All right,
there was a friend of mine that was older than me and he was always looking for
the right girl and the right girl to settle down with and to marry and have kids
and all that stuff.
And it never seemed to happen.
And the reason it never seems to happen is cause he was always looking for
perfection,
always looking for perfection.
And
I told him that,
you know,
profession doesn't exist.
And I also had another buddy of mine that was,
we were like surfing and he was always looking for like the next good time.
Always looking for,
he's looking for happiness,
right?
And One time we're surfing and I go,
Bro,
you keep looking around for happiness.
This is it.
This is it,
man.
We're surfing.
This is happiness right now.
Do you
ever feel like you're searching too much and looking for something
instead of enjoying what you have?
10 years ago I would've said yes.
Right now,
I feel like I've found,
I found,
uh,
a few things,
meaning realizations and
I view my job as testing things on the fringe and reporting back psych half like
ethnobotanist might be eaten by cannibals plus a little bit of athletic
stupidity
and really trying to find the things that the extreme so I can inform the mean
and as an experimentalist or an experimenter,
I've viewed that as my responsibility,
my job.
And I've also replaced a number of words in my life.
So we,
we used happiness because it's just the easiest reference point for a lot of
folks.
Uh,
I think that the
better word,
his excitement.
So I,
I chase what excites me.
Now that's a razor's edge you got to be careful with.
But when I say excite,
it means I wake up excited and I go to bed exhausted basically is what that
means.
And,
uh,
I've also realized that
there are things to optimize and there are things to saver and I don't have a
lot of trouble with that.
Most people would think that I'm just like speed reading poetry and watching
every movie on like 28 x forward with subtitles just to cram in as much Mr robot
as I can or whatever.
And No,
I,
I feel like I am increasingly better at the appreciation portion of the
equation.
The achievement I've always been,
I wouldn't say hardwired for,
but very well trained for.
I'm good at putting goals in the sights and achieving those goals.
But if you're constantly looking for the next thing,
whether it's the next goal or its the next girl or it's the next high,
then you are never going to be operating in the present tense.
Was there something that you said 10 years ago,
if I would ask you this,
you would have probably been on your heels a little bit.
Is there something that happened that you said you don't want?
What did I just,
you know,
did you get home from a trip one time and say what did I just do?
Or what was there?
No,
I can tell you,
I can tell you that it was,
um,
so this,
this is related to something that,
you know,
Robert Rodriguez,
who's the director,
producer,
writer,
musician,
everything is fascinating guy,
also huge.
I didn't realize how big it was.
So sin city good on the list,
right?
He's,
he has a lot of hits.
And he said,
I always find it funny,
and I'm paraphrasing here,
but uh,
he's,
he's one of the longer chapters in the book.
He said,
I always find it funny when filmmakers come up to be brand new filmmakers and
they say nothing went the way it was supposed to go.
Like this happened and that happened and shit broke and then we missed this shot
and Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
And he said,
they don't realize that that's their job,
that nothing is going to work.
Like if you're the director,
your job is nothing's gonna work.
Uh,
so at one point I was feeling,
uh,
maybe existentially scattered.
I was like,
well,
I'm trying all these different things and doing all these different experiments
and what am I going to figure out my thing?
And then at some point someone just said,
no,
your thing is going Meta.
Like your thing is doing these types of experiments.
And what I realized is my,
my one thing is learning things quickly and whether that is cooking or
sniping,
I've taken some sniping courses,
that's a separate story.
Ah,
rally,
car racing,
whatever,
right?
Tango doesn't matter that the approach to deconstructing these things and learn
them quickly compounds.
So if I get better at one,
I get better the next,
it doesn't matter what the subject area is.
So that's my one thing.
Uh,
and it just gave me great peace of mind.
A,
you don't need one thing in a traditionally defined sense.
Maybe your thing is as I have found,
you know,
being a human Guinea pig and trying to train people to be better learners is my
one thing.
Uh,
and that,
that made me feel more confident,
uh,
in this sort of experimental approach.
I don't have 10 year plans and I used to,
that used to bother me a lot.
I am no longer remotely bothered by that.
Uh,
because I have two week experiments and I have six month projects,
and if I do my,
we actually talked about this and you've written about it,
but rather than worrying about the,
the next 17 promotions,
you just do what's in front of you.
In my case,
to say it's a book project,
if I do an exceptional job,
I knock it out of the park with this one thing.
Opportunities will present themselves that I couldn't have conceived of six
months ago.
And then it's just a matter of for the wave.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
But I'm a lot better at appreciation than I was along,
uh,
say 10 years ago,
because 10 years ago it didn't matter how,
how will I did what I won,
what I accomplished,
I was always obsessing on the next thing.
I never took the time to actually enjoy it.
Good lesson.